alright leute heute ist der tag wie
laden heute drei andere youtuber ein und
es hat auch in bestimmten grund denn ihr
erinnert euch vielleicht daran wir haben
jetzt zwei videos zusammen mit reiner
schick gemacht zu haben geguckt wie
schnell glas eigentlich bericht und dann
haben wir einem anderen video auch noch
aus panzerglas geschossen und auch auf
ein handy geschossen
jetzt haben wir aber gestern das alles
abgedreht und diese high speed kamera
diese superklasse teure high speed
kamera für zwei tage gemietet und haben
heute quasi noch einen ganzen tag zeit
um mit dieser kamera zu machen was wir
wollen und wir haben auch schon eine
ganz geile idee aber ich glaube dass es
nicht so ganz im sinne des herstellers
geladen hatte wir würden wir uns gerne
mit der highspeed kamera eine tesla
spule für die hat allerdings 500 1000
volt
[Musik]
ok erst mal alles auf anfang
wir sind gerade von unserem ersten
drehtag mit der highspeed kamera zurück
wir waren gerade auf dem schießstand und
wir haben nur diese high speed kamera
noch den kompletten morgigen tag bis 23
uhr wir müssen hier um elf uhr abends
zurückgeben an die kamera verleiht
bis dahin können wir mit dieser kamera
machen was wir wollen
meine idee ist jetzt also lasst uns doch
einfach mal gucken was wir alles filmen
können was in highspeed und in slow
motion richtig richtig geil aussieht
da gab es nur ein kleines problem ich
hatte überhaupt keine idee wie wir etwas
ist so schnell auf die beine stellen
sollten
[Musik]
schritt 1 wir brauchen experimente
deswegen haben wir direkt ein paar
andere youtuber angerufen und konnte
tatsächlich vier leute von drei youtube
kanälen organisieren
jetzt gab es ein weiteres problem viele
der experimente sollten laut heiß sogar
ein bisschen gefährlich werden also
schritt 2 so macht man sowas hier bei
uns im studio war definitiv keine option
und direkt vor der tür ist eine
befahrene straße also mussten wir
schnellstmöglich eine location finden wo
wir so lange und so viel wie möglich
drehen können und dann haben wir
wirklich einfach alles am telefonieren
parkplätze schrottplätze sogar
irgendwelche open air kinos am ende
waren wir sogar fast so weit dass er
einfach aus köln raus auf irgend so ein
trecker fahren und hoffen dass wir da
keinen ärger kriegen aber alles gut
liebe des ordnungsamtes ist nichts
passiert wir haben dann doch eine
location bekommen das klingt doch super
dann würde ich sagen dass später alles
klar
danke schön da
wir haben zu tun
[Musik]
es ist unglaublich heiß und wir sind die
ganze zeit fassungen nicht was man die
super ist weil genau das brauchen wir
für die high speed kamera aber für uns
menschen ist das einfach heißt mit
verdammt viel glück haben nicht nur
irgendeine location bekommen sondern
konnten spontan einen club mitten in
köln mieten der verdammt cool aussieht
und wo wir so viel dreck und so viel
lärm machen konnten mit unseren
experimenten wie wir wollten und die
werden von verschiedenen youtube handel
gebracht zum beispiel da passiert gerade
schon was zb marcel fantastisch markus
von den physikanten oder auch jacob alle
haben cool experimente mitgebracht und
wir erklären heute wie ein high speed
kamera funktioniert
als erstes ist jackpot von science
fiction gekommen und dann kommt es auch
schon losgehen
seifenblasen film drüber und was ich
erwarte ist die seite an seite blase die
baut sich so auch platz irgendwie und
der nebel von dem trocken heißt wir
haben noch stehen bleibt dann
hoffentlich wird das ganze richtig
beantworten und mitgeschnitten
[Musik]
1 die 1
ein lautsprecher sieht ein bisschen aus
wie eine kochschürze kann man das rein
machen
ich habe was mitgebracht das ist sehr
lecker schmeckt auf jeden fall so wie es
heißt black es ist eine mischung aus
maisstärke und wasser nicht minutengenau
genau wie ich das richtig schnell drauf
haut eines beton genau genau wird so ist
es natürlich genau also wenn wir hier
drauf wenn du willst genau darauf
richtig doch mit dem genau dann ist es
fest
und wenn du aber so kannst du es ganz
langsam durch gleich gesagt das ist
genau die viskosität nimmt zu je mehr
kraft du drauf packt und das coole ist
da der speaker ja permanent vibriert
wirkt permanente kraft auf das black und
dadurch bei uns dass wir hin und her und
verfestigt sich und das gibt kohle vor
was wir uns jetzt an
so ist das dj pult ich glaube immer noch
an genauen drei mal ein bisschen raus
mein base are based on
oh ja jetzt als richtig
wieso ein kleinstaat schon fast in
diesem business leben ist ein haustier
auf jeden fall lange
das war davon noch ganz viele tausend
närrinnen das könnte aber auch wegen dem
auszeit mit 8 abend oktopus sei paul es
verliert den kopf kriegt ihn wieder und
das ist zum mutterschiff
[Musik]
es nutzt ein bisschen wir müssen mal
gucken wie weit die funken dann kriegen
darum wird es gehen
321 und
markus du bist von den physikanten und
du hast uns riesig richtig cooles
mitgebracht was ist das für eine
kontraktion hier
das ist ein fettes kondensator case also
hier befinden sich sechs ordentliche
kondensatoren drin die latte nun auch
mit einer spannung von 3000 volt richtig
viel elektrische energie gespeichert
hätte ich die angst hast du zu recht
weil wenn man im falschen moment reißt
du willst du einfach tot also das ist
wirklich sehr sehr ehrlich was wir
machen und das geht durch diesen draht
also es reicht um einen menschen zu
töten und es geht durch einen kleinen
draht und dieser draht wird und zwar
viel einfach nicht nur pulverisiert der
wirt weg so und wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwie explodieren so und wie das
ganz genau aussieht das möchte ich da
sind sich aus bilder pro sekunde ist auf
jeden fall ziemlich viel da kannst du
quasi wenn du eine sekunde aufnimmt und
sie das dann in 25 bilder also nochmal
quasi an gut und flüssig dauert es
ungefähr ein bis zwei stunden für eine
sekunde die sich dann beruhigt sich den
roten knopf und dann passiert ja ich
muss erst mal laden
ok ich jetzt wirklich die 80 prozent 90
prozent 100 ok 321
das ist werden wir ein herz explodieren
lassen
[Musik]
es regnet am heißesten tag des
septembers
also kommt man hin ist es blauer himmel
aber es regnet ich weiß nicht wie das
gehen kann
die zustimmung mega bombe
zum schutz wenn sie mit einer banane du
lachst rufen wir haben wir nun der gosse
liegen mit wirklich grandios wie
funktioniert so eine kamera also ich
habe jetzt mein handy das kann manchmal
120 fps schon aufnehmen wir haben solche
kameras hier die können auch manchmal
bis zu 240 fps aufnehmen
aber das ist ja nicht ganz andere welt
nie wie geht so was natürlich ist der
datendurchsatz der kamera ganz anders
also der der datenfluss vom sensor vorne
auf das speichermedium in die kamera das
macht ihr kamera teuer je schneller die
das kann im super geschwindigkeit kann
man damit erreichen aber umso teurer
werden ich habe gehört die das rechne
man auch in riga pixeln pro sekunde also
man kann sich ja dann immer entscheiden
zwischen ich möchte jetzt mehr fps oder
mehr auflösung haben dann aber die liga
pixel pro sekunde bleiben die gleiche
genau das ist jetzt weiß ich vorher mit
datendurchsatz meint hat das ist diese
größe also das ist schon gut im rennen
fährt also die ist ganz klar auf
stimmigkeit getrimmt die kamera kann
jetzt hier bei ich sag mal vernünftigen
auflösungen bis 2050 1000 bilder pro
sekunde und wenn man die auflösung
verkleinern kann man bis 600 700 800
1000 bilder pro sekunde aufnehmen
deswegen natürlich stark ab braucht die
auflösung die dann noch zur verfügung
steht für die anwendung noch aus weiß
dass kohl sterne geschichte ist
eigentlich dass man sehr vielseitiges
also vom automotive bereich car crash
militärbereich und auch im kino für die
kinoproduktion zum beispiel und du hast
jetzt immer von von einem ring speichern
gesprochen das was bedeutet dass das
hatte auch damit was zu tun
ja das ist schmonzette symbolsprache
also das ist kein speicher der
ringförmig ist drin sondern ring
speicher soll eigentlich nur
verdeutlichen dass man schon speicher
anfang bis bauende aufnimmt also bild 1
bis ende und dann fängt die kamera
einfach wieder an von bildein zu
überschreiben
und es macht die permanent also
ringförmig die sind abbuchen passiert
und man kann über die software sagen die
kameras soll zum beispiel beim halben
ring speicher die daten behalten
und dann hat den vorteil wenn man zum
beispiel das problem von einem
vorstellen wasserspringen kennt weiß
nicht wann der vor schluss bin dann
stelle ich meinen ring speicher so ein
dass ich den speicher genau die mitte
stellen und kann dann wenn das vor
springt auslösen und hab dann nicht gute
chance dass ich sowohl den absprung als
auch die landung im wasser dann im ring
speicher in der zwischenzeit hat der
regen aufgehört also weiter geht s denn
wir haben noch super viele experimente
vor uns quasi keine zeit mehr sich
tausende kameras bewegen das war uns das
risiko als nächstes fahrzeug taste
strand er hat wohl esa training
mitgebracht also nicht die spaghetti
soße sondern glas diese kleinen gebilde
werden auch prince rupert drop genannt
und entstehen wenn man einen tropfen
flüssiges glas in kaltes wasser gibt das
glas kühlt dann schlagartig ab und
erspart so zu einer träne die am dicken
ende unglaublich stabil ist es reicht
aber den schwanz der trainer ab zu
kneifen um die gesamte energie wieder
freizusetzen und die träne explodiert
und genau das wollten die mit der fans
und einfach
[Musik]
ja ok
platz
tatsächlich ist das meist geklickte
video auf dem kanal von texas tisch über
polonaise tränen die nicht kaputtgehen
stabiler als diamant schreibt er dem
titel und das beweist er hier ziemlich
eindrucksvoll denn die tränen wollten
vor ort einfach nicht richtig
explodieren wie man sie dann doch kaputt
bekommt das erfahrt ihr in seinem video
auf dem kanal von texas tisch das gerade
online gegangen ist das verlinkt ich
auch noch einmal im abspann so langsam
lief uns aber vor ort die zeit davon was
macht man also wenn ein experiment nicht
ganz so läuft wie man es will
schluss laborglas
[Musik]
die
all das ist zu anstrengend
heute dreht sieht vielleicht für euch
mega witzchen cool aus oberdrees super
super anstrengend ich bin froh dass wir
alles abgedreht haben vielen lieben dank
an rang schielt die uns dieses mega
kuhlemann strohmann kamera einfach in
die hände gegeben haben die sache macht
was immer ihr wollt sehr cool danke für
das vertrauen aber wirklich was
besonderes für uns weil wir noch nie mit
so cool und krassen equipment gedreht
haben und für euch gibt's auch was
besonderes und zwar 20 prozent rabatt im
rainer schild stores haben wir noch nie
gegeben und zwar mit dem kot watson 20
auf alle produkte im wallis dort zum
beispiel auf so poole hüllen die euer
handy schützen zb mit dem space shuttle
oder könnt euer eigenes bild drauf
machen doktor watson logo oder wenn
jetzt müssen minimalistischer möglich
mit holzmaserung aber ihr könnt eure
bluetooth kopfhörer schützen oder ihr
könnt eine folie drauf machen 20 prozent
rabatt für die nächsten 48 stunden
allerdings nur nachdem dieses video
online gegangen ist mit dem kot watson
20 oder der erste link unten in der
video beschreibung dankeschön auch an
die ganzen youtuber die so spontan
einfach so nach köln gekommen sind weil
wir gefragt haben und experiment
brauchten dankeschön an tektas tisch und
ein jackpot die mal eben so nach köln
gekommen sind von mega weither
dankeschön an markus von den physikanten
der im ganzen wären an experimenten
mitgebracht hat von denen wir leider nur
ein bruchteil heute zeigen und drehen
konnten also geht gerne zu denen auch
die kanäle die machen alle super videos
schreibt gerne unter deren aktuellstes
video vielleicht ein dankeschön von
doktor watson will mir auf jeden fall
sehr viel bedeuten habe ich sehr dankbar
bin dass diese youtube so schnell vorbei
gekommen sind
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen
bleibt neugierig und bis zum nächsten
mal
er sagt ich gehe jetzt ins bett
ich habe jetzt heute schon viereinhalb
gehabt
das reicht erst mal triumphiert nicht